now one of my fantasies
is I want to drive by like a woman's
rally and just say the most sexist [__]
I can think of just to watch him lose
their minds
and I'll just drive by real slowly like
yeah why don't you get back in the
kitchen where you belong
rear view mirror watching a flash
flipping out on the road
spinning around like Leatherface at the
end of Texas Chainsaw Massacre like
[Applause]
yeah no it's a very uh
I don't know times are changing I guess
I don't know
yeah Michelle Obama's doing an arena
tour
that's another thing going on I'm going
to say that again Michelle Obama
is doing an arena tour she's not playing
comedy clubs
she's doing arenas
when did first lady start acting like
they got elected
you know
to be the first lady that's not a
[__] job just standing there smiling
and waving
right
look how quiet is it in here why is it
so [__] quiet you think that's a job
it's not a [__] job
dude if you really think it's a job just
look at him right look at Obama when
that guy got elected he looked like he
was about 41 years old when he left
office that guy looked like he was about
73. right
look at Michelle she looks younger now
than she did when that dude got elected
[Applause]
what has she done for the last eight
years
yeah other than laying a giant vat of
Illuminati level lotion just sit here
slowly
a couple hours a shape-shifter comes in
and dumps another bucket on it anymore
pops your head up hey Bam Bam tell Steve
he wanted to come down and play some
songs tonight
I found out she's doing a tour because
uh she's doing a book tour
yeah she wrote a book she wrote a book
about not having a job
I gotta read that [__] book
chapter one how to know if a dick tastes
presidential
[Applause]
all that local representative [__] and
get to the big swinging dick in the room
I'll tell you right now say what you
want about Republican presidents but
they got their first ladies in line
they do
George W was President for eight years
eight years I don't even know his wife's
name
what was it Abigail or some [__] Maggie
no clue
Donald Trump's wife stands behind him
like a giant meerkat like
Bill Clinton was President his wife
didn't have a shutout
knocked around on her so much he's like
all right whatever just do it
but I'm telling you right now I'm gonna
I'm gonna check out that [__] tour I
gotta see what that's all about you know
who opens who opens on that [__] tour
was it Oprah Winfrey's husband you know
[Applause]
you [__] come out and talk about what
it's like to walk her dogs
I do it for 20 minutes a day the Cocker
Spaniel's probably the most fussiest and
I gotta bring him around
look I'm sure that there's some uh
feminist in the crowd right now not
appreciating this joke feeling triggered
feeling like they need to [__] put
out a hashtag or some [__] and be brave
and speak out
okay
you know what you're full of [__]
you are
oh
all all those feminists are full of [__]
because I'm gonna tell you right now
someday someday there's gonna be there's
gonna be the first woman president all
right which means which means you don't
even know why you don't even know what a
[__] platform is and you
automatically cheer
safe genitalia
[__] I'm telling you they're not
smart people feminists they're not as
smart as they're coming off I'm telling
you
someday
there's gonna be
by the way it's gonna be my last show
ever by the time this [__] thing
comes out
someday there's gonna be the first
female president which means there's
going to be the first male first lady
right
and you wait
wait
the first time now that dude open
political [__] you watch all these
feminists they're only you shut the [__]
up you shut
her time now
she was the
[Applause]
last [__] you are the First Lady
he's gonna get treated like Tom Arnold
when he was with Roseanne
Secret Service name will be like
appendix or doesn't matter
and just enter the oval office not
worthy of protecting
who do you pick I got no idea so I've
just been like regressing like I can't
deal with this [__] I just want to hit
pause I don't want this election to
[__] happen so I've just been
regressing and I'm just watching the
dumbest [__] I possibly can you know
morning time those stupid talk shows to
get soccer mom's day started you know
they have those all those non-thinking
stories you know you love them he's your
best friend but did you ever wonder what
does your dog do when you're not home
the next video may surprise you and I
just fill it up fill up my brain with
this dumb [__] I don't want to deal with
what's really going on
Nationwide heroin epidemic [__] that
it's National Taco day we got Tony from
Tony's Taco Tony what is it that makes a
great taco
oh it's all about starting out with the
tortilla all right watching them making
pancakes and all that [__] talking to
the ladies talking about body issues
they're always talking about body issues
that's the dumbest one ever when they
talk about Hollywood going like
Hollywood they create these impossible
body Images blah blah blah you know that
whole thing the plus size actress right
the fatties
yeah
that's like a big thing them they're
sick of being treated like fat people
I don't know what it is they're doing
they're going on the cover of magazines
now just like showing how fat they are
we're in a little bit of amount of
clothes and everybody's like hyping them
up like oh my God that's so brave that's
so courageous
I'm not saying it doesn't take balls but
that's a bit of an overreach with the
word brave
right
like what am I supposed to do if I ever
see a fireman running out of a building
carrying a baby and an old lady am I
going to sit there like oh my God you're
like a fat actress that takes their
shirt off to do a magazine shoot to
promote the movie she's in
now look I know you're not supposed to
make fun of fat people I understand all
right I don't know why though
why they're not a race they're not a
religion it's totally curable eat an
apple and go for a walk you know why are
you yelling at everybody else
the [__] are you giving me [__] for all
right you put the cookies in there I
didn't
how is this my problem
Jesus Christ you ain't your way in you
can walk your way out all right and just
slowly start shedding the pounds shove
some [__] lettuce in there instead of
a bunch of ho-hos and it's it's gonna
come down
and then you're on my side of the fence
right join me come on stay with me Shame
Shame
right
I know you're not supposed to shame
you're not supposed to Fat shame you're
not supposed to [__] shame
they're like shaming shaming like people
aren't supposed to walk around with any
shame it's like a legitimate human
emotion but you're not supposed to feel
it at all you know you're supposed to
just walk around like a dictator just
not you know not gonna feel any shame
you never felt shame
you never had such a bad [__] night
the next morning you woke up you
couldn't even look yourself in the
mirror when you went to go brush your
teeth he looked up you're like oh you
[__] piece of [__] wow wow even for
you that was bad lights out curtains
drawn until at least two in the
afternoon before I can even look at you
you [__] piece of [__]
yeah you're supposed to have no shame
that's the new world you're just gonna
walk around sucking dick you know eating
cookies and just show up and nobody's
supposed to say anything no one's
supposed to have an opinion like well
that's that's going to go off the rails
pretty soon
I know it's probably mean to do this
stuff but like you can only have so much
sympathy there's so much so much stuff
you can care about you know what
happened to me that changed my life I
did a gig in India right unbelievably
great people but some of the stuff that
I saw there I'll never forget I
literally I did a gig in India I saw a
toddler take a [__] between two parked
cars walked away no pants or parents and
then disappeared into the crowd like
Hannibal Lecter at the end of Silence of
the lamps
it's one of the most heartbreaking
things I've ever seen in my life and
then I come back to my country and it's
like oh the studio said I lose 50 pounds
to star in a movie when it start running
you fat [__] that's your big complaint
in life
dude I gotta be honest I hate how scared
I'm getting this I get older I'm
developing all these new fears like I
have a fear of flying now I never had a
fear of it it's not straight across the
board flying I don't like small planes
all of a sudden
I just don't like man it has nothing to
do with the plane I believe in the
planks
okay I just don't believe in the pilots
because you know what I don't think the
airline does either
which is why that dude is flying that
little plane
the airline was basically like all right
we'll give you like 28 people
see how you do you know you fly him out
the land you bring another 28 back we'll
let you do this for a while you do this
for a while we don't get any complaints
no up and down up and down no none of
that [__]
we're moving up to 35 people then one
day you'll be in a jet whoo we're going
a little faster right
big planes you're getting the [__]
pilot that knows what he's doing he's
probably fought in the War he's used to
getting shot at he can't bring this bus
in it's a joke right
a bunch of people whining in the back
hey headphones don't work he doesn't
give a [__] right he's up there sleeping
trying to make something happen he's so
goddamn bored that's a set up there
right
so one time I'm flying into Albany New
York okay a city that nobody really goes
to so I'm on a smaller plane and
everything's going great all of a sudden
out of nowhere we hit this turbulence
[Music]
right and it stops and everybody looks
around like laughing nervously like oh
oh
all of a sudden it comes back with a
vengeance
you can literally hear like the metal
the planes made out of like
all of a sudden this dude like three
rows back starts making like these
[__] noises like whoa
I'm gonna lie I have never been so [__]
scared and my entire life
dude that noise is acceptable out of a
female or a child
turn around and see a 37 year old
mustachioed male going
look the hair was standing up on my arms
I'm praying to a higher power I don't
even believe in the [__] I just wish I
had the balls to turn around be like
dude would you shut the [__] up Jesus
Christ be a man push it down push it
down deny your feelings act like you
have answers do some man [__] right now
do some man [__]
Jesus Christ
you know you think I'm not up here
thinking I am
foreign
T help us for me to join you and turn
this fuselage into a haunted house you
know
you know what kills me what absolutely
kills me is some woman is going to fall
in love with this guy marry him and make
half [__] kids
and you know what we become weaker as a
species
we do
I I will get married you know I was
making that I'll definitely get married
someday you know I don't you know I love
women and everything I'm just fine and
I'm not like compatible with them you
know what I mean
if I just feel that like women have like
too much energy for me you know what I
mean like you can't have a day off when
you have a girlfriend you ever notice
that it's almost like they see that open
day they're like oh my god let's go fill
it up with [__]
no then they just come at you with one
horrible idea after another
horrible ideas like you want to make
some sandwiches and go to the park
you want to go to The Container Store
get some containers for your t-shirts
this is the worst one
there we get this one want to go to
brunch
you want to go to brunch on Sunday and
inside you're like [__] no
you can't say that right
you gotta keep them happy so what do you
do you agree like yeah let's go to
brunch
what a great idea
why would you want to sleep in on a
Sunday when you can go pay 18 for eggs
now you're thinking
what are you thinking
then we can sit around to listen to your
friends have moronic conversations about
the eggs like is that pesto
is that pesto in your omelette oh it's
asparagus it's asparagus I thought it
was testo
oh you just want to flip the whole
[__] table over
it's horrendous
I'm trying to learn to pick my battles
when I date girls I usually argue with
women all the time man I'm stupid like
that you know like I did to this girl
one time she was like really into like
women's issues
so we used to always have these dumb ass
arguments like one time she came up to
me she goes okay explain this to me Bill
why does a guy make more an hour to do
the exact same job huh
I go I'll tell you why because in the
unlikely event that we're both on a
Titanic and it starts to sink for some
[__] up reason you get to leave with
the kids and I have to stay
[Applause]
yeah that's why I get the dollar now
think about it
if there's a house fire it's always
Women and Children First I gotta stand
there with like the back of my shirt on
fire going Let's go people let's go
let's go
so that's how I look at it
no it's a dollar an hour surcharge
that if something [__] up happens
either I can't leave or I gotta like get
in the way of it to give you a head
start like rabid dog run honey One
Mississippi two Mississippi
you hear a bump in the night I gotta go
check it out like yes he does have a
knife
anytime there's a hostage situation who
do they negotiate for first well at
least let the women and children go
what about me
bullets hurt me too why the [__] do I
gotta stay in the vault
no that's my point man where are all the
feminists in those situations
you don't mean you can't find them
they are no feminist in a house fire
that's a guarantee you could take the
most hardcore feminist some chick right
in your face like he's showing this
thing kind of a [__] a little short
little haircut the whole nine yards
right
second those Flames break out she's
gonna twist those little hairs into
pigtails no I'm just a girl I want to go
play jump rope
and leave you standing in a burning
house like you're not flammable
you know but I'm not I'm not a dick
though
I'm not I'm not saying I think a woman
should make a doll less an hour to do
the same job all I'm saying is we're
gonna make what I make when the boat
sinks you better be standing right there
next to me listen to that guy Play The
Cello then you get the corner office
you get all the benefits or whatever
till the other night somebody broke into
our car sitting in the driveway starts
[__] with her head right so she
starts reading up on guns you know she's
reading too much because now she wants
to get one but she's just like well I
heard you got to keep the bullets in the
safe keep the stock in the garage and
then what then what I run around the
house and assemble it there's some dudes
chasing me with an ax
you know even thinking this thing
through sweetheart running around
where's where's the scope it's in the
living room he's in the living room
we're getting this thing I want that
[__] thing loaded right on the
bedroom wall right there I'll put that
thing on my jam Jam sleeves just like
that
there's no other point
That's funny though when you talk about
getting a gun you know people like they
either totally afford or completely
against it you know they either go nuts
and start screaming right well they
start throwing out those stats yeah
actually you you increase your chances
of getting shot by 80 percent the second
you get a gun in the house
really what because I'm going to load it
and shower with it like
[Applause]
[__] I know it's dangerous
you get a pool in your backyard you
immediately increase your odds of
drowning in your backyard right
you couldn't do that before now you step
on a rake and you go
no I'm telling you
I don't buy in any of that [__]
stats are so [__] stupid you know
not that they're stupid it's the way
people apply them you already have your
mind made up and then you go to
omright.com you start memorizing a bunch
of [__] and then just just throw it up
at people
this guy tried to get me to go scuba
diving I go I'm not going I don't want
to get eaten by a shark he's like well
actually 90 of shark attacks actually
happen in shallow water it's like no
[__] that's where the people are
yeah it's called the beach
80 of people are frolicking along the
coastline
people swim into Europe let's go to
Iceland your [__]
right
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
it's in New York I had an active gig all
right I was playing a fireman all right
now I'm not the best actor right some of
you saw it I hope you paid for it you
cheap bastards
um you all watched it for free you
bastards
so anyways I'm not the best actor so I
have to look the part so I grew this
giant you know fireman mustache big
stupid fireman mustache which looked
great when I was wearing the whole
fireman get up and they put the fake
dirt on my face I look like I've been
fighting fires for 20 years all right
however the second I took off the
costume and they cleaned off my face and
I put on my regular clothes I
immediately just look like some saddled
queen that never found love right
and as luck would have it
I was in New York City in June which I
quickly found out was gay pride month
the whole month and let me tell you
something the gay guys show up strong it
is wall-to-wall the [__] island is
almost tipping over there's so many of
them and I'm sitting there like going oh
my God 30 days of this [__] I'm walking
around with this orange Freddie Mercury
[__] dick broom on my face
I'm gonna be getting harassed up and
down the street I was an actor Shake man
I was [__] shredded I gotta tell you
something man
when I tell you 30 days of June not one
gay guy even [__] looked at me
forget about even hit on me I have never
felt so old and undesirable in my life
dude I'm gonna tell you something it's
it's one thing as a man when you get so
old that women don't look at you anymore
like you know you're gonna hit that age
you know that Day's coming but nobody
tells you at some point you're gonna get
so old not even a man wants to [__] you
right
dude that is a statement when you get so
old
some Queen in his 60s is that keep it
moving I can do better than that Jesus
Christ
the [__] hair plugs or something get
a spray tan I get something that's 40.
keep going
dude it was like I was like having like
this [__] panic attack I was thinking
like oh my God I waited too long to get
married I had kids too late I'm gonna
die soon I was like literally like
wrapping up my life you know so I'm
walking down like 9th Avenue
you know putting a little swish in my
[__] step just trying to get
something I was desperate [__] you
ladies you've been there you know how it
is
you want to feel honest if you got one
more in it you know
so I'm traveling on down the street
I really wish that wasn't the truth so
I'm going down Ninth Avenue and all of a
sudden I looked up at about two blocks
away all of a sudden I see this lesbian
coming up the block okay now I know this
is Boulder Colorado right so you guys
are all like [__] hey man you know
like how did you like know she was a
lesbian man like that's not cool you
just looked at her and you just knew she
was a lesbian
you don't know her how did you just
how do you just know somebody's a
lesbian
easy
the same way you do
the same way other lesbians do
it's not calculus
no but I get it I understand in 2021
you're not allowed to say you know what
a lesbian looks like right
judging by your silence yes right
yeah you're not allowed right well it's
funny is some white kid came in here
like 20 years old hair slick back
colourpopped loafers no socks you'd be
looking at them thinking like all right
Pratt boy date rapist his dad's a judge
he's not going to jail
yeah just killed five people in a
drinking and driving accident already
has a new Dodge Challenger on the way
right
yeah you're allowed to see that that you
can see clear as day
[Applause]
lesbian
I am not
no but that's how Progressive you guys
are right
you don't have any idea
right like let's play a game
I'll just name different people you see
and see the slides that come into your
head right
construction worker
sports fan
painter
skateboarder
lesbian
all right it all goes black all right
all right
is that a lesbian
I mean I have gay friends but I've never
noticed any sort of a through line
listen people I'm not saying all
lesbians look alike I would never say
some ignorant [__] like that however
I am saying though every once in a while
there's a [__] layup
top wallet chain [__] walking up free
but even then even then I'm not saying a
hundred percent but gun to my head I
gotta go lesbian
about lesbian Final Answer Final Answer
show being lesbian
right
[Applause]
so anyway
she's [__] she's [__] walking up
the street
I'm coming down right
and it's clear to me
that if we keep walking the way we're
walking we're gonna bump into each other
now I don't want to bump into a woman I
don't want to bump into anybody in New
York so I do the genuinely thing I clock
what's going on so what I do is I just
gradually shift over into my own lane
now everything's fine right but then the
weirdest thing happened we walk like
another 30 yards and all of a sudden she
drifts back into my lane again and I'm
sitting there walking like wow that was
it's kind of crazy
thought I solved this problem
all right so I [__] dip into another
land again right okay I'm walking we go
another 30 yards she comes back into my
lane again so now like I'm up against
the curb
so now I'm like thinking like okay how
do I do the politically correct math
here like what am I supposed to be doing
here am I supposed to like [__] am I
supposed to step off into the bike lane
and have some some young kid on his
electric bicycle come by 40 miles an
hour run me over I go down to the
pavement knees and elbows for the rest
of my life every time it rains I got to
think about this lesbian that walked me
off the [__] block is that what I'm
supposed to do
am I supposed to give up the whole
sidewalk like oh oh oh oh oh your
gayness right
or
do I stiffen up my shoulder
and protect my leg right
[Applause]
now I'm not proud of this but I chose
the ladder all right
I was like look I'm 53 I move twice I
have an AARP card I'm the [__] victim
here so
so I stepping up the shoulder and then
immediately I'm thinking like okay this
is gonna get crazy I have never done
this with the female before this is in
public people are going to see this [__]
what's gonna happen right but I'm not
gonna lie to you she started closing in
she was moving so I like leaned in like
I really got my legs underneath me
because she was built like a janitor and
I was not gonna get spun around I wasn't
getting spun around not having that on
the [__] logbook right so I lead into
this [__] and at the last second she
turned her shoulder and we just missed
shoulders but our forearms still slapped
together was significant enough force
that it warranted a turnaround
okay I know most you guys drive so I
will break down pedestrian etiquette
really quickly
in New York City this is the deal if
you're walking down the street in New
York right you're walking you're walking
and then you just sort of brush sleeves
with somebody you don't have to stop you
can just look over your shoulder hey
sorry man my bad have a nice day right
then this the next level moves up a
little bit you're walking down the
street you actually bump into somebody
you actually have to turn around sorry
didn't see you little Dojo bow my bad
whatever you have to do my Sensei to
keep it from escalating
and then there's the last one you're
just walking down the street and you hit
so [__] hard you got to turn around
and go like old school Dustin Hoffman De
Niro like hey a [__] walk in here huh
I [__] moved twice you didn't see
that you drifted two times huh
so I turn around to have this
confrontation
and let me tell you something she never
looked back
and I'm not gonna lie to you that bugged
me
that bugged me for like three days
three days I'm just walking around New
York just [__] goddamn [__]
[__] there's no [__] way you
didn't do that on purpose who does that
who dressed you know and I'm feeling I'm
feeling this anger
it's just burning me up and I know
eventually it's going to settle in my
chest and then one more time it's gonna
be I sorry Dada hi sorry it's like I
can't do this I can't do this to my
daughter I can't do this to my kids so I
started reading up on anger
like how to let go of [__] I think is
what I Googled
and I found empathy if you have empathy
for somebody you put yourself in their
shoes you can just you know figure out
where they're coming from where you're
coming from you can meet in the middle
so I said all right here we go let me
put myself in her shoes what would cause
somebody to accidentally drift into your
lane twice you know so I just started
throwing [__] on the wall oh here we go
did she have a club foot no did she just
have a stroke did she have Bell's Palsy
of her left side you know
was she a mummy did she have a wooden
leg you know is she one of those yeah
you know those those [__] diagonal
Walkers you get behind him at the
airport you know they're walking too
slow you try to go around to the right
they start dragging their suitcase over
there we go over to Alaska coming back
this way you know it's like they just
got off a ship and everything was just
like no no no no no no no no no can't
right no I'm still mad
still [__] mad
so I said out gives a [__] I don't give
a [__]
lied to myself said I didn't give a [__]
you know so then I ended up going home
then I'm home and I'm washing the dishes
which is a very zen-like thing to do
it's like a week later you know you wash
dishes you're not thinking of anything
your brain is empty I'm washing the
dishes and then all of a sudden the
answer just came to me it just floated
into my head
and I just looked up I was like oh my
God
I know why she did it
I know why she bumped into me
she bumped into me because
she's a lesbian
I mean it was right I was like looking
nine miles down the street looking under
shrubs it was right in front of my face
she did it because she's a lesbian
all right so judging by most of your
silence
I will do this math for you come on
let's have a little empathy here put
yourself in a lesbian shoes
all right
who do lesbians think women
who do they do who do they do they move
in with women who do they get in
relationships with women who do they
eventually marry women and I was
thinking like oh my God I did that
I know what the [__] that's like
I know what it's like to live with one
of those [__] things
I know exactly what that it's hopeless
trying to make them happy hey I might
get the shiny thing that I do it right
huh trying to get him take
responsibility for their actions not
gonna happen
the best you're gonna get is I'm sorry
but
I know what it's like to be winning a
[__] argument you're winning you're
winning you're winning and then they
turn it around they're crying you're
apologizing you think of what the [__]
just happened how am I losing this [__]
I had you on the ropes you feel so dumb
you gotta go for a walk and you're just
thinking how did I lose again
how did I lose again and then you figure
it out it makes you feel stupid and then
you see some bald idiot with a giant
orange mustache like you know what why
don't you take some of that [__]
you take some of that [__] anger
yeah